c'est le vol mythique sur la Réunion
celui dont rêve de nombreux
parapentistes internationaux après 1 km
de marche au départ du point de vue du
Maido on s'élance comme un Papangue pour
planer au-dessus de mafat Sébastien
coupi moniteur breueté et agréé pour les
vols en biplace nous fait partager ses
images et ses sensations lors d'un vol
au départ du Maido les vols du Maido
c'est un cadre assez particulier parce
que c'est un vol qui se prépare et ça
marche pas à tous les coups parce qu'on
a besoin d'avoir des conditions idéales
pour le décollage au Maido c'est un
décollage qui est très court avec très
peu de courses d'envol
c'est un petit peu quand même un vol à
tous les niveaux qui est un petit peu
stressant au décollage parce qu'on se
demande toujours à quelle sa ça va être
mangé au décollage et ensuite la
surprise c'est de savoir si si on va
avoir les conditions qui vont nous
permettre de monter a-dessus du rempart
ou
pas
c'est un décollage où on se fait souvent
arraché par le vent on a besoin de d'un
petit peu d'air il y en a souvent
là-haut pour décoller du Mao mais c'est
surtout un décollage qui est
fabuleux pour le la vision de du CIRC de
mafat
en il y a que du Mao qu'on peut décoller
pour aller au-dessus de
mafat
on se retrouve assez vite lors de ce vol
au-dessus du le long des du relief et on
fait ce qu'on appelle du sing en fait on
arrive à tenir avec ce vent dynamique
qui remonte le long des pentes et qui
nous empêche de descendre alors il faut
essayer de tourner aux endroits qui
montent le plus pour garder cette
hauteur le long du rempart et petit à
petit on arrive à gagner de la hauteur
gagner de la
et le gral c'est de passer au-dessus
donc au bout de d'une demi-heure de vol
on va arriver à passer au-dessus du
relief et à ce moment-l on a on a la
possibilité de basculer sur sur Saint-
paaul et c'est ce qu'on va faire et et
là c'est c'était super beau parce que il
y avait pas beaucoup de nuage une
luminosité exceptionnelle et surtout qu'
on était trois pilotes en l'air on s'est
t suivi et on est rentré dans le
rest
les conditions doivent être excellentes
pour voler au mail d'au euh parce que
parce qu'on a droit qu'à un seul essai
pour le décollage il faut pas qu' alors
il faut pas qu'il y ait trop de vent
sinon on peut pas décoller on reculerait
avec le vent et on pourrait pas avancer
dans ma fat quand il y a pas de vent du
tout c'est compliqué parce qu'on a pas
assez de place pour gonfler la voile et
et gagner suffisamment de vitesse pour
pour prendre l'envol et décoller dans ma
fate donc il faut euh c'est compliqué il
faut le vent idéal c'est qu'il faudrait
qu'il y ait entre 15 et 20 kmh deent
au décollage c'est pour ça qu'on y va
pas tout le temps et c'est pour ça que
les gens qui ont la chance de voler au
Mao bah c'est vraiment une chance quoi
parce que c'est pas tous les jours que
ça se passe comme ça que ça se passe
bien en tout
cas moi dans la vie j'aime bien tout ce
qui
est tout ce qui est plaisir et je trouve
du plaisir à autant de plaisir à aller
voler au ma parce que c'est un petit peu
le le la mousse au chocolat qu'on rêve
d'avoir de temps en temps et puis hop
quand elle arrive c'est génial on la
croque on mange tout
he